in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Scott
and Meg are with us hey guys how are you
good how are you
we're doing awesome better than I
deserve welcome welcome it's good to
have you were you guys from Ogden Utah
Ogden Utah it's a bit of a haul to
Nashville yeah to do a debt-free scream
we're excited about it very cool and how
much have you paid off a 150,000 excuse
me $125,000 110 all right you paid off
your house you did I'm looking at where
your word totally I love it and how long
did it take you to do that
15 months that's pretty radical you what
is your range of income during that time
anywhere from sixty thousand to a
hundred and twenty thousand in 15 months
uh-huh so somebody took a job well we
both were working I got a in an upgrade
in my job so I went back to school and I
got an advanced degree so okay so how
much did that bump you I'm good probably
$30,000 yeah good for you so what's your
degree in what do you do I'm a nurse
practitioner oh okay yeah that that
little kick will work every time that's
a good ROI on that degree yeah yeah very
nice and what do you do Scott I'm a
residential consultant for a heating and
air conditioning company so just running
the residential leads for okay very cool
good for you guys oh very well done you
two so what happened 15 months ago that
made you decide hey we're gonna focus
and pay off our house and be weird so
Scott came home one day and he's like
I'm just let's just pay off our house
and I said well are you crazy because
we're young nobody pays off you don't do
that and other people don't do that I
just looked at him like he was crazy but
when he started going through what we
could do with our income it it seemed
pretty doable so we just went after it
Wow I mean you threw almost $10,000 a
month at this yep
so did you have some in savings we did
hi we had a good ten twenty thousand in
savings okay so that got you going
and then you just rolled up your sleeves
in this boy what did you do um we lived
within our means way yeah we had yeah we
didn't a bunch of our friends were going
on vacations and going out to eat all
the time and we just kind of buckled
down and said now we're not gonna do
that we're gonna just live within our
below our means so four at a time sure
yeah I mean 15 months later how old are
you - I'm 27 and you got a paid-for
house you do any vacation you wander the
rest your life great you can eat
anywhere you want to eat you can afford
it you make a one hundred twenty
thousand dollars a year you don't have a
house payment
it is so Scott what made you think this
could happen um just looking at the
numbers I've sat down and broke them
down the biggest thing that frustrated
me is I looking at our mortgage bills
looking at how much interest was going
to the bank and not into our bank
account and then it was mainly just
getting angry at that and not wanting to
do that anymore what made you believe
you could do that all of this what made
you look at the numbers um makes career
advancement and her motivation to do
that was certainly incentivizing to me I
I guess I just believed we needed to
make it happen that wasn't a question of
if you just how soon we could get it
done yeah sure what made you want to
come - all the way to Nashville to do
your debt-free scream this is a huge
moment for us and we we really
sacrificed to get here so I mean we
don't kind of wanted to cap it off with
this to come out here and undo the
screen fine fine so you listen to us and
Ogden I guess we do yep okay you've got
a big following in northern Utah yes we
do a bunch of folks very cool we
appreciate it - very nice
okay and I miss Nora is with you is that
right she is and how old is Nora she's
almost 1 in a couple weeks almost 1
we've got a couple of them at this age
our grandbabies we call it the
pterodactyl stage because they just
scream no apparent reason randomly it's
just amazing it's wonderful
sort of yeah but this is great oh she's
cute cute kid very fun now she has no
idea what her parents have done I'm so
proud of you guys you have completely
changed your lives in your family tree
your heroes you took the the courage to
say we're gonna do something completely
different and you've set yourself up to
be able to live like no one else and now
you can live and give like no one else
very very well done we're gonna give you
a copy of Chris Hogan's book number one
bestseller retire inspired signed by him
cuz that's your next step build wealth
become very very wealthy and give a
bunch of it away that's where you're
headed you're a baby step seven people
man I love it
we need to like give out t-shirts maybe
seven seven or something just took just
a throw people off what's baby step
seven yeah yeah well I'm 27 and I'm
already there I love it very good you
guys are awesome all right it's Scott
and Meg and cute Nora from Ogden Utah
house and everything baby a hundred and
twenty-five thousand dollars paid off in
15 months making 60 now up to 120 with
the advanced degree in all the extra
hard work count it down let's hear a
debt free scream 3
way to go you two very well done very
well done what beautiful family it's a
complete change of a family tree there
it's absolutely amazing a couple that
did their debt-free scream last hour had
just gotten married 11 months ago and
we're debt-free 11 months later they
dove in and did it their parents both
went through Financial Peace University
so they were second generation FPU so
that's what a little Noro will be well
Noor is one years old that was just on
the air there do you understand where
she's gonna be when she's 20 where her
parents are gonna be oh well let me help
you just in case you were unclear about
the power of the mathematics on this
let's just say they had the average
house payment we'll just pick out say
$2,000 a month let's just say they don't
have a house payment anymore so they're
gonna pay just a house payment that's
all they do nothing else they just save
a house payment that's all they're gonna
do we're 20 what 27 years old so I will
go 67 years old that's 40 years Oh 40
years from now starting out with nothing
if you save $2,000 a month for 40 years
and a decent growth stock mutual fund at
12% that would be a twenty three million
so let's just say I'm so stupid I'm 90%
wrong because some of you don't like my
calculations and you of course can bite
my ankle but let's just say you don't
like my calculations and I'm 90% wrong
they're gonna have two million dollars
three million dollars but they're more
likely gonna have 10 to 20 million
dollars
maybe 30 million dollars oh by the way
that's they only saved a house payment
from age 27 age 67 they didn't put
anything in their 401k they didn't max
all of that out they didn't have any
other wealth building their income never
went up we just assumed that they're
completely stupid and they don't do
anything except they have a house
payment their whole life that's the
power around your house paid off in your
20s twenty million dollars twenty
million dollars so little Nora is gonna
have a good life that's
we're saying 20 million dollars well
that's just fast-forward okay 40 years
from now she's a fat old girl's 40 years
old mom and dad are 67 mom and dad are
70 right there's 20 million dollars
do you understand we just do that they
just changed their family tree and if
I'm half wrong its ten million dollars
but if you're wrong it's thirty million
dollars and if we're way super stupid
wrong it's three or four or five million
dollars that's just the house payment
that they don't have anymore do you
understand how much debt is costing you
do you wonder why the bank's all have
towers in the skyline and you live from
paycheck to paycheck broke that's why
you are making them rich that 20 million
dollars it's going to countrywide
mortgage it's going to floor voter
credit that's what that 20 million
dollars is going freaking five hundred
dollar average car payment right now
just new numbers out four hundred ninety
nine dollars a month now the average car
payment car payment house payment twenty
thirty million dollars over your working
lifetime for those of you in your 20s
are you listening you're giving your
life away to these people don't do it
anymore get out of that this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
the cop
you